[Musica]
no è che seriamente consta felpa sembro
san francesco non so perché non è un
cosplayer una felpa seria questa stella
tutti ragazzi è pervenuti a questo nuovo
video sono felicissimo torna di nuovo
vlog prima di cominciare con i video
ragazzi come al solito partiamo con la
fama della settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta da giulia che ha
fatto studi segno che dov'è il disegno
più bello che io abbia mai visto
però è troppo tenero e non poteva non
vincere veramente troppo tenero e stata
una settimana difficile perché ho
passato metà pomeriggio a giocare ad
uncharted vi sono spaccato di uncharted
4 come se non ci fosse un domani che poi
giocare ad uncharted mi è servito un
sacco adesso so fare un sacco di cose
tipo posso arrampicarmi
[Musica]
1724 la fine di uno youtube che poi
ragazzi io vado a periodi in realtà
perché ci sono dei periodi in cui gioco
a qualcosa di periodi in cui guardo
qualcosa tipo serie tv tipo prima che
uscisse uncharted ho iniziato a guardare
american horror story e continuava a
guardarmi puntate su puntate comunque
ragazzi durante la settimana mi sono
visto con i miei amici abbiamo passato
un po di tempo insieme quei ragazzi del
gaming abbiamo fatto un sacco di cose
tipo andare in macchina
[Musica]
ovviamente io sono sempre scarrozzato
perché non ho la patente però con nichi
box abbiamo fatto un gameplay di gta
recentemente che mi lascio questo
spezzone figo
c'è dell'ignoranza e tanta quello
desiderato all'ombra succede per vedere
il video completo poi di gta guardate
sul suo canale che lascia in descrizione
hai fatto sono anche venuti a casa mia
adesso che mi ricordo e abbiamo fatto un
sacco di cose divertenti tipo la spesa e
amici che mi fanno la spesa quando mi
vengono a trovare
grazie ragazzi senza di voi potete
tornare a casa che mi state dando
fastidio ragazzi tutto sto bordello a
parte passiamo allo scattato dei pacchi
che meglio hanno una cosa non vi ho
detto non vi ho detto anche se penso al
abbiate visto tutti su instagram perché
l'ho pubblicato su instagram che è
uscito il ventennale di repubblica che è
un inserto speciale di repubblica che ha
pubblicato una foto i 20 ragazzi di
vent'anni tutti belli incravattati tutti
belli in fi dettati e indovinate anche
che minchione c'era in mezzo a quei
ragazzi
proprio così guarda che bel giornale di
moda quanti bei ragazzi quanta bella
robert ma che ca figo che minchia san
francesco esposta e non è la posizione
da pornodivo che mi spaventa ma la
outfit poi questo slang di gamba non so
anche come ho fatto a farlo però siamo
allo scatto dei pacchi ragazzi che è
meglio che bello che quelli di oggi non
sono pesanti
già che goduria quando riesco a portarli
di avere il primo ragazzi ce ne sono 6
prova con amber one è la madonna senza
figata norma che figata ragazzi vita
sarebbe utile se sapessi iscrivere per
fa vj il più grande youtuber del mondo
grazie fratello questa cosa mi inquieta
e non poco però grazie serate massei
specializzato in disegni da psicopatici
questo è bello almeno sorride è già
qualcosa
ave ragazzi passiamo al prossimo
bellissimi però i disegni io non so
disegnare un bene però nostri monti
davvero mi ha regalato most wanted non
cerca lo sapevo che non c'era un cazzo
denti che simpatico
altro giro altro pacco ragazzi la
maglietta della juventus fa vince perché
c'è un impiccato dal perché l'abbiamo
poverino io posso maiman giro così next
one ragazzi questa rosa antico egitto
devo avere paura zero cosa c'è in un
cofanetto dell'antico egitto spiega
avere giusto non avevo proprio dubbi c'è
anche una scatola è una figata c'è anche
una pergamena male noi ragazzo mi hai
mandato sto pacco dall'antico egitto ci
sono dei sì mi sono nascosto io sono
data andrei per scoprirlo
vabbè magari dopo che ho fatto un po di
allenamento è ma la pergamena c'è
scritto il kraken
mancano due ragazzi passiamo al primo
dei due è la madonna fosse un fatto
serio una conchiglia grossa ma è vero è
finta conchiglia conchiglia significa
mare mare significa pirati pirati
significa tesori
all.re come ultimo ma non per importanza
abbiamo il pacco giallo dove mi ha mai
detto no non è bellissimo ha notato solo
adesso che non so le mani perché sa
perché c'è che mario col taglierino
bello ma perché zoro per quale motivo è
venuto benissimo tra l'altro la madonna
questa geniale questa è fottutamente
geniale quindi ragazzi dire che possono
più del qui il video di oggi prima di
concludere volevo farvi una domanda per
chi ha giocato a lanciarti ma come cazzo
fa nathan drake ad aggrapparsi alle cose
su cosa posso fare pratica per diventare
bravo come lui sui grattacieli quelli
alti se sei un haters lai pensato brutto
stronzo spera video vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi cose che mi è piaciuta suo
documento è un mi piace anche la pagina
di facebook come video trattare
descrizione senza lussi di scafati ci
vediamo questo video ragazzi ma non è
che flash crash 3 2 1
micheli che nick e samba saint amour
ogni scelta
niente se vorranno american horror story
perché mi guardo americano rossori in
quasi sempre quando marmora che flash
che fastidio e niente me lo guardo sul
portatile a volte mi finiscono di
montare il video perché io molto anche
il video ogni tanto l'ho portato io ho
montato a ogni e poi mi metto a guardare
le puntate di mameli piano spesso di un
cazzo sto messo male io nella vita
va beh vado a farmi un bel te che te tra
la mia stanza di notte
si vabbè io devo sommare i computer